you know not doing it
hi I'm Ben Affleck I'm here with the way
back and this is start to bench good I'm
gonna be giving a category with three
choices I'm gonna choose one to start on
the bench and yes one to cut they all
start none can be cut and none can be
benched Paul bearer's and genius David
Ortiz in the most clutch hitter of all
time and Tom Brady's the best football
player I ever played again only a fool
benches are cuts those guys I mean maybe
trade I guess start Belichick bench
Popovich and cut save it
Dave Roberts stolen base and Oh for
Malcolm Butler's interception and 24
comeback the Celtics made a game for
that those are all great well I would
say Dave maybe start Dave Roberts stolen
base and cut the selfish come back and
bench Malcolm Butler mid know start
rockin Butler bench Dave Roberts and
yeah the Oh for a league championship
series was the most amazing thing I've
ever seen in the sports it's cut Isaiah
Thomas and Brad Marsh none you can eat
out if you get out he can start and be a
bed
that would be a deep entourage you
imagine if I roll the Gronk and Manny
Ramirez just those two right
I mean Manny is I fact there's a thank
you to Manny and Ortiz at the end of
Gombe be gone because I think they
either combined like 90 bombs that year
I'll start man II gotta work with them
again at some point not doing it I'm
really excited about the movie March 6
it opens it's called the way back you
gotta go check it out it's very very
good